Hi everyone, I'm Steve Brunton from
the Universityof Washington and
I've been looking forward to making this video for years.
Today i'm going totalk about how we can model very complex
fluid dynamics systems using sparse non-linear modelingtechniques from machine learning.
This is one of my favorite topics, and this is an area of active research in my lab here at UW.
In 2016 we published a paper where we could
build sparse non-linear models from data
of systems, and we looked at this simple laminar
flow past a cylinder... this was our kind of bigexample
in our 2016 paper. And so in this lecture,
I'm going to tell you about what's happened in
the last five years and some of the big strides
we've made in extending this to much more complex
fluid dynamic systems.  So from one cylinder
to this three cylinder configuration that has more
broad band turbulence.  We're looking at electroconvection systems, so this is a complex three-way
coupled device.  We're looking at cavity flows
okay, so really really interesting, rich dynamics of
this cavity flow... all the way up to spheromak
fusion reactor simulations,
We can build these sparse nonlinear models.  Turbulent wake flows,
with our experimental collaborators in Europe,
So very excited to walk you through some of
the progress in sparse nonlinear models of fluiddynamics
In all of these cases, we are going to
find models like this: xdot = f(x)
where x is a low dimensional vector that describes
the dominant coherent patterns in these flows
so out of the very complex millions or billions
of degrees of freedom you would need to simulate
these on a computer we're going to extract the
three or four or five most important coherent
structures in x and f is going to be the dynamics
that describe how those coherent structures
evolve and interact in time and that's
going to be a sparse non-linear dynamicalsystems model
So that's what we're going
to do today, and I'm going to jump right in.
so i want to acknowledge that this has been
work with lots of great colleagues co-authors
collaborators great students in postdocs on this
so the sparse non-linear modeling work started
out with nathan kutz and josh proctor where
we developed lots of the mathematical theory
and extensions of the algorithm and then we've
extended this to many many fluid systems with
baron nowak uh jc louiseau from paris tech george
regas from imperial uh college and i want to also
acknowledge uh the army and the air force funded
um most of this work so uh and all of this was
done by our excellent uh students and post-docs
on these projects okay good uh so i want to start
off i'm gonna start off on my soapbox here this
is uh kind of my entry point when i talk about
machine learning so many of you have heard this
before if you listen uh in and you've seen some
of my talks there is a need for interpretable and
generalizable machine learning methods so instead
of you know we know that neural networks are super
powerful but they're kind of opaque they're black
box so we want machine learning models that
are more interpretable and generalizable and
instead of defining these i'm just going to make
enemies if i try to define these things i'm going
to give you an analogy okay so in my mind the
quintessential interpretable generalizable model
is f equals m a so it's interpretable because it
has three terms f m and a they have units i can
write down these equations for a particular system
of interest and analyze them and we can discuss
what those terms mean it's interpretable
it's generalizable in the sense that newton
can learn f equals ma from apples falling on
earth or so the story goes and that same model
is valid when we design space missions to land
humans on the moon okay that is a generalizable
model now i have no doubt that if i had movies of
apples falling i could train a deep neural network
to make another movie of an apple falling but that
would not be useful to land humans on the moon
it wouldn't be generalizable in this way this
is the kind of model that we want in engineering
sciences in fluids especially because so many of
our applications of fluids are safety critical
like flight and we can't afford to not understand
our model and we can't afford for it not to work
in a regime where we didn't expect it to be and
this is not just newton this idea of of kind of
mathematical modeling being as simple as possible
but not simpler is one of the cornerstones of
mathematical physics einstein observed this this
was observed by aristotle 2000 years earlier
akam pareto you name it great minds have
been you know adhering to this principle
of parsimony or simplicity to get
these kinds of models in physics
and so what that means for us today mathematically
how we're going to use this in fluid dynamics
is we are going to build low dimensional models
models in terms of only the few variables that
matter the coherent patterns in the flow
we're going to extract those low dimensional
representations and we're going to build sparse
dynamics models for how those low dimensional
patterns evolve in time together okay and
low dimensional and sparse are the two
mathematical ingredients that are going to give us
interpretable and generalizable models in fluids
so sparse models on a low dimensional
state vector so fast forward 300 years
and in the modern era we see a great analog of
this in the chaotic thermal convection problem
the rayleigh bernard convection so this is a very
cool fluids problem where you have a hot plate on
the bottom and a cold plate on top this is kind of
a model for how the atmosphere convects when the
sun hits the planes and the air starts to warm
up and cause these large convection cells and
this fluid flow equation is what motivated lorentz
in 1963 to develop the famous lorentz model
now i'll point out i've added the names feder
and hamilton so this is linda feder and margaret
hamilton they were his graduate students who
helped him run these super computer simulations
to generate the data he used to build his model
so i think it's important to remember their
contribution that's the margaret hamilton of nasa
fame so she went on to do many many great things
and what lorentz was able to do was take this very
complex fluid flow field and distill it down into
these three equations you see on the right and
you'll notice that this has exactly this the low
dimensional and sparse nature that we talked about
before so it's low dimensional in the sense that
lorenz is characterizing the system with three
variables x y and z that describe three spatial
modes that you can add up to approximate this
flow field and those modes were posited earlier by
saltzman at yale and it's sparse in the sense that
on the right hand side out of all of the possible
things that could be in the dynamics there's only
seven terms okay so it's sparse the interactions
of x y and z are simple and there's key mechanisms
where they interact through sigma y and minus
sigma x and things like that so that's going to
be kind of this key theme is building these low
dimensional sparse models and we're going to do
this in an automated way so what i'm going to show
you today is how we are automating what lorenz did
in 1963 for more complex flows today with machine
learning and with data okay so this is the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics algorithm or
cindy this is the the 2016 paper i was talking
about uh with nathan kutz and josh proctor and
i'm going to walk you through this on the laurent
system so imagine that we have the laurent system
and i'm simulating data but all i have access to
is the data i don't have access to the equations
so i measure x y and z in time so i've got a time
series of these measurements and i compute x dot
y dot and z dot they're time derivatives so i
don't know the equations but i do have data now
the simplest thing you might think of to do is to
build a linear regression model a best fit model
that tries to fit x dot y dot and z dot in
terms of a linear model a times x y and z this
is exactly what dynamic mode decomposition or dmd
does now we know that a dmd model this is a three
by three linear model with a single fixed point at
the origin there's no way it can capture this rich
complexity of the lorette system with multiple
fixed points unstable periodic orbits and chaos
so instead what we do is we augment the right
hand side with more candidate terms in the in
the dynamics so instead of just linear terms x
y and z we add x squared and x y y squared y z
all the way up to in this case fifth order
polynomials z to the fifth and all of these
gray columns i can actually build those from the
data i collected in x y and z and now the trick is
we're trying to find the fewest columns remember
we want sparse models the fewest columns of theta
that add up to equal x dot that add up to equal
y dot and then add up to equal z dot and when you
do this you uncover it turns out that the fewest
columns that add up to equal x dot y dot and z dot
highlight the original terms that were in the
dynamics that actually generated this data
now this is non-linear system id we're
generating these models directly from our data
even though we've never seen the equations before
so the sparse optimization if you had asked me 20
years ago if this is possible i would have said
no this is a brute force combinatorial search
but it turns out that now this is uh pretty
much a commodity algorithm in statistics
to find these sparse linear combinations so
there's dozens of algorithms to compute these
things and to find these sparse representations
uh if you build your your library correctly now
i'll point out in this case we assumed that we
knew the right measurement variables x y and z
and that's a huge assumption that i'll
come back to later okay good if you're
interested in trying this we have open source
software called pi cindy in python and you can
download this on the github and read about
it in the journal of open source software
good so we don't just have to build ordinary
differential equation models and here we're
going to start thinking about fluids again
we can build partial differential equation
models so this is a great work by sam rudy who
is a phd student working with nathan and me
where he collected full spatial temporal flow
fields for the fluid flow past a cylinder and
instead of building just an ordinary differential
equation problem he builds a library of partial
derivatives uh and and nonlinear products of
partial derivatives and when he applies the same
cindy sparse regression procedure you essentially
find the uh the sparsest model that's consistent
with the data are the navy or stokes equations
here and you'll notice that these pink terms
are the one over reynolds number they're
within one percent of the true value so pretty
remarkable just from data by applying the sparse
regression you learn the navy or stokes equations
using sparse regression now because the spatial
temporal data is so rich there's so much of it
we can dramatically subsample the data we can
measure at a few random locations in space and
time and even on that sparse subsample data we can
still identify the same navy or stokes dynamics
so this is pretty cool okay good now i told you
earlier that we assumed that we knew the right
coordinates x y and z for lorenz so there was
some really important work by kathleen champion
this was also when she was doing her phd with
nathan and me where she essentially combined
the idea of a deep autoencoder network
from machine learning and our sparse cindy
models that i was just showing you and so the
autoencoder learns a coordinate transformation
where your dynamics becomes sparse in the latent
variable z and so this is a simultaneous discovery
of coordinates and of sparse dynamics so really
cool work here and kathleen actually has a
great video lecture on this uh that i'll link
below so you can you know read all about this
and and see her her lecture okay good uh
so now i really want to dive into how we're
using this in the field of fluid mechanics
okay so i'm going to go through vignettes
of how we're doing sparse nonlinear modeling to
get reduced-order models of complex fluid flows
so this reduced order modeling paradigm again i'm
going to walk you through what we started doing
in our original 2016 paper and build from there so
this is our simple low reynolds number flow past
a cylinder this is a canonical example of vortex
shedding and bear noack and collaborators in this
famous 2003 jfm paper told us the right coordinate
system the right low dimensional variables to
measure this this flow in so the first two proper
orthogonal decomposition modes or singular value
decomposition modes and this third shift mode
which is the unstable steady state minus the
mean flow and if you model if you measure the the
flow past a cylinder in these three coordinates
you can write down a very simple non-linear
quadratic model here in blue that gives rise
to the transient and steady state behavior of
this system this is a famous paper and it was
famous because it wrote down such a simple model
for this flow uh using kind of simple arguments
and this dynamical system in blue gives rise to a
slow manifold and it's very kind of interpretable
sparse and low dimensional and so this is going
to be the example we're going to warm up and try
cindy on to get a sparse model so we are
going to measure this system in those same
three coordinates and we're going to take x y
and z and feed those into our cindy algorithm
and when we do that we uncover a model that has
essentially the same terms as the noack model
and it has the same slow manifold our identified
system has the slow parabolic manifold
and it captures the same transient and
steady state dynamics as the original
noack model so this is pretty cool we
were really excited when we saw this
very soon after putting this paper on the archive
i got an email from john christophe lazo he was
at kth at the time now he's at paris tech and
he had two key innovations that really upped
our game in modeling fluids with cindy so the
first observation is that when we do this sparse
cindy regression we're not taking into account
any background knowledge about our flow but jc
knows that incompressible navy or stokes equations
conserve energy and he says they conserve energy
we know how they conserve energy through these
skew-symmetric quadratic non-linearities and so
in our sparse regression you can essentially
add constraint equations so that the terms
the quadratic terms have to be skew symmetric
and by doing so we make it so that our models
our sparse models conserve energy by construction
so that immediately improves the stability and the
learning rate of our models the second thing
he did and this is i think really important
is include higher order non-linearities into the
model so in our original model we had quadratic
non-linearities because we wanted to match bear
noak's model and we knew that the navy or stokes
equations had quadratic non-linearities but when
you allow yourself to have higher order terms
cubic quintic septic nonic so third fifth seventh
ninth order terms you essentially are accounting
for very low energy modes that we've truncated or
neglected and how they affect the large energetic
modes we are trying to model so by adding cubic
and fifth and seventh order terms to these x
and y equations we essentially account for these
higher frequency mode pairs that we have neglected
these low energy but high frequency mode pairs
and so what you get are much more accurate models
and it's in some sense a rudimentary closure
model for this very simple laminar flow
so i want to be careful in calling this a
closure model because this is not turbulent
but it is kind of closing the truncated scales
and how they affect the large energy scales
so let's see how this works on the cylinder flow
and on the cavity flow two of my favorite examples
what we see here in the middle
column is kind of our benchmark
a delta is a quantity that's essentially
a prax a proxy for the drag so this is a
quantity of interest we want to model in the
system and the white curve is the ground truth
from a direct numerical simulation so when we
start off the simulation the drag rises and it
goes to some steady state value and in yellow
and in blue these are the industry standard
state-of-the-art pod galarkin models we basically
take the proper orthogonal decomposition
and we glur can project the navier-stokes
equations onto either three modes or seven modes
so we see that these models and these are
the kinds of models baron noack was building
in that 2003 paper so we see that these are
qualitatively pretty they capture the right
features but quantitatively they're off they have
the wrong rise time they overshoot and they have
steady state error whereas when we introduce our
cindy models with either cubic non-linearities or
constraints built in we almost perfectly capture
both qualitatively and quantitatively the dynamics
now here's a really important point i want
to make because these cindy models are
sparse it's literally a sparse differential
equation with as few terms as possible
it is interpretable jc and i can write down
this equation and go get a coffee in paris
and and manipulate and analyze that equation and
that's exactly what he did and he wrote down this
differential equation from the cindy model for
cylinder flow and showed that this system is
essentially a spring mass damper with a non-linear
damping term or a van der pol oscillator
and this is to date the simplest and the
most accurate model of the cylinder flow
that i have seen on on record because of
sparsity because of the sparse regression
okay good now we have extended this to more
complex flows like this fluidic pinball that
has three cylinders and has much more broadband
uh behavior in the wake and importantly we don't
need the full flow field or someone to tell
us what coordinates to measure this system in
we can build our sparse models directly from lift
and drag measurements of these three cylinders so
those are kind of obvious measurements you would
take you don't need the full wake velocity field
measurements you just need six measurements of
the lift and drag on each cylinder and you can
build these very very accurate cindy models that
match the dns the direct numerical simulation
very faithfully so i think this is super cool
this accounts for some of the issues of um
you know proper orthogonal decomposition often
is is going to fail if you change the flow
velocity or i change the geometry or i move the
bodies but building models directly in lift and
drag coordinates is really nice because those are
intrinsic and those mean the same thing even when
my flow velocity changes even when my geometry
changes okay good so now we're going to go on to
some more complex examples so i'm going to go back
to the chaotic thermal convection rayleigh bernard
and i want to highlight this really cool
work by jc that he put out last year in tcfd
where he was analyzing this chaotic thermosyphon
so it's basically a hula hoop or an annular
region that's heated from below and cooled
from above and it creates and sets up this
thermal convection cycle that's chaotic
similar to the rayleigh bernard convection
and so what jc was able to do by extracting modes
automatically through dynamic mode decomposition
and modeling the evolution of those modes in time
with cindy he was able to show that this chaotic
thermosyphon flow is structurally the same as the
laurent 63 model for rayleigh bernard convection
for a completely different geometry and so this is
a really really cool result very nice paper kind
of showing that lorenz is even more general than
we thought to these other flows and that you can
automatically model them using these techniques
so that model was not written down for this
before jc and so this is a real new scientific
discovery very cool we've been working
on other convection problems so this
is work by ife guan and igor novosilov
ife was a phd student working with igor he's
now a postdoc at rice and he was working on this
great electro convection problem so electro
convection is a little bit more complicated
than standard rayleigh bernard because it has
a three-way coupling between the fluid flow the
charge density and the electric field which sets
up these rich kind of chaotic convection patterns
and so what we did here is started trying
to apply these automated sparse modeling
procedures to get low order models of this chaotic
electro convection so we collect spatial temporal
data in time in space and time we extract the key
modes the low dimensional features the energetic
coherent structures that matter using proper
orthogonal decomposition and then we look at
how the amplitudes of those pod modes evolve in
time so a1 is the amplitude of the first mode
a2 is the amplitude of the second mode and so on
and these are how the mode amplitudes evolve with
respect to each other in time and we observed we
noticed that this flow has deep deep symmetries
there is an incredible symmetry when you look
at these mode coefficients of how the energy
is being transferred through these modes and so
we were able to learn those symmetries to write
them down and to enforce them in our cindy model
so this is using that that same technique john
christophe lazo taught us we can now add those
symmetry constraints directly into our cindy model
so we get a non-linear model that it
satisfies those symmetries by construction
and we get this sparse model that has the same
skeletal kind of structural dynamics it misses
some of the details but it captures the big
features of this flow very nicely using this
and we can get the flow fields by adding up
these pod modes in these a1 a2 a3 combination
so let's zoom in a little more and look at
these symmetries so this is the phase portrait
of those pod amplitudes and we can write
down these five symmetries that we observe
in the system it's invariant uh to switching
the sign of a2 or switching the sign of a3
and so on and so forth there's these invariants
in the in the data and so what that means is that
when we write down our cindy library the library
of possible nonlinear terms and the dynamics a lot
of them immediately have to be zero we've blacked
out a lot of these terms that can't be active with
these symmetries being observed and even more than
that there are other conditions like you know this
sigma 2 has to be the opposite of this sigma
2 and so on and so forth there are these kind
of additional constraints on the cindy library
that have to be true based on these symmetries
and so when we enforce those in our cindy
regression we can get away with less data because
there's less coefficients we're trying to identify
and we get more stable more accurate models
in this case again we get this model
here that has the right structure
of the of the data now it doesn't capture every
small feature there are these little loops here
we're not capturing but we get a lot of the
features of the data and kind of this chaotic
uh electro convection so very promising that you
can scale this up to pretty sophisticated systems
again we didn't have reduced order models
for this when we started this is a new model
and you can analyze this kind of
how lorentz analyzed the 63 model
so another great example this is work by alan
captain auglu who's a phd student working with me
on plasma physics so he has a three-dimensional
simulation of a spherimack fusion reactor here
that is matched to experiments and he has
from this simulation data of this 3d system
extracted again the low dimensional features we
care about using pod and he had to cook up his
own dimensional pod since you know your magnetic
field and your velocity field have different
units so that we had to can make a conversion so
they can speak the same language and then in this
coordinate system you're able to build a sparse
nonlinear model that satisfies the constraints of
the pd of the mhd equations and down here you see
that our reduced order model our sparse nonlinear
model captures the structural dynamics of this
spheromac fusion reactor very very accurately
so this is very promising we're starting to
add things like injector dynamics and control
so that we can use these reduced order models
for online control of experiments hopefully so
that's where this is going is these models are so
fast and so efficient and they seem to be pretty
accurate maybe we can use this for something
like model predictive control down the road
okay good so um i'm just going to keep going
because i love this stuff and we've got more
i've been kind of blown away with the progress
in the last few years if you had asked me two
years ago if some of these flows were possible to
analyze with cindy i would have said probably not
but with great students and great collaborators
we've started opening up a lot of these problems
and complexities so one of the ones i'm really
excited about this is new work by jared callahan
a great phd student of mine and jc lazo that the
archive paper should be coming out very soon where
we're analyzing more complex higher dimensional
systems like this shear driven cavity that has
if you did the proper orthogonal decomposition
you would find that there might be a couple dozen
modes that are energetic and important and so
when they analyze this flow uh of course you
have the shear layer instability and you have
the inner cavity modes like this is classical
theory we know that these are dominant kind of
mode structures that give rise to these dynamics
but in a purely data driven fashion again when
we look at the mode amplitudes versus each other
in time so a1 versus a2 a2 versus a3 and so on you
see this incredibly rich correlated structure here
that's highly indicative of nonlinear dynamics
and so by identifying the two driving mode pairs
uh jared and jc were able to build this
extremely simple cindy model up to fifth order
that almost perfectly captures the dynamics of
the full nonlinear simulation and if we zoom in
we can look at the power spectrum of the log of
the energy and you know we have power peaks from
the cavity mode and the shear layer mode we
have power peaks from kind of these harmonics
the second harmonic the non-linear crosstalk
and higher order harmonics and our cindy model
almost perfectly captures all of them this
blew me away when i saw this absolute beautiful
agreement of many many modes all the way up to
like a19 in this case that's the 19th pod mode
so we're capturing the full spectrum of this
cavity again with a two state cindy model and then
kind of how they impact these higher modes very
cool you can read about this soon on the archive
and another thing kind of i'm really excited about
that i wouldn't have thought is possible a couple
of years ago is extending this to full-blown
turbulent systems so turbulence is hard because
you have coherent structures but they're forced
by multi-scale structures that you don't want
to model or or necessarily kind of keep track of
and so this is worked by jared jc and george regis
where we essentially are modeling the longivian
dynamics of turbulent fluid flows so here we have
x dot equals f of x that's our original
cindy model for the coherent structures
plus sigma w this is a noise term a colored noise
term that forces our dynamics stochastically and
so what we're doing here is we're simultaneously
identifying the sparse nonlinear dynamics of
the coherent structures and the color noise
forcing of all of those small scale turbulence
fluctuations that are forcing the system this
is closely related to the focker planck equation
which describes the evolution of distributions
or ensembles of trajectories but we're taking
the launch of an approach and i'll point out we're
building on prior work by bona sega and clementi
and others that extended cindy to longivin
systems for molecular dynamics so we've extended
it to higher dimensional fluid systems and i'm not
going to jump into all of the details here because
it's a little bit involved but the basic idea is
that we're parametrizing our nonlinear dynamics
and our noise just like in cindy and then we're
finding sparse non-linear models by fitting the
data by essentially building distributions and
by adjoint optimization trying to find sparse
c vectors that model these nonlinear dynamics and
noise forcing and in all of the cases we've looked
at from simple toy examples to fully turbulent
wake data from experiments we get very simple
structural models for the coherent structures and
a very simple representation of the colored noise
forcing from the subscale turbulent fluctuations
that we're not modeling or we're not keeping track
of and just to illustrate this on the cavity flow
this again is the full direct numerical simulation
and down here this is our longivin reduced order
model so you can see that we're capturing kind
of the key dynamics of these pod modes these
kind of figure eight dynamics but we're also
getting the spread of the dynamics because
we're accounting for this noise forcing
that broadens uh those trajectories very very
cool and it seems to work on this fairly turbulent
uh sorry not not this but on really turbulent
data like wake uh wake data from from experiments
okay good um so i think the last thing i want
to show you i've shown you a lot this is the
whirlwind tour of sparse non-linear modeling
of fluids the last thing i want to show you is
pretty new and it's a little bit of a different
take on sparse modeling again with jared callahan
um uh james koch nathan kutz and bing
brunton and this is sparse modeling of
terms in equations uh to see which terms balance
each other at what locations of space and time
so there's this idea of
dominant balance in physics
where even if you have a very complex equation
like the full 3d navy or stokes equations
maybe at a place a location in space only a
few of those terms are active and large and
are kind of balancing each other out while most
of the other terms are small so this is the idea
of dominant balance and it's the foundation of
asymptotic analysis and asymptotic expansions
most of the applied math departments in
the country grew up out of this idea of
asymptotics and dominant balance in physics
where you could write down solutions on pen and
paper by hand before computers by simplifying the
equations to a few key terms that are interacting
and what jared's going to do on this johns hopkins
turbulent boundary layer is automate this dominant
balance procedure with machine learning and
sparse non-linear modeling so if you take the
reynolds average navy or stokes equations the
rand's equations here you see that there are
in two dimensions there are six terms and for
each of those terms you can essentially plot
what that term's magnitude is at every point in
space so this is one term in my equation at every
location in space on the boundary layer and you
can plot all six of those equation terms like this
so this is essentially an equation space
representation so now for every point i can take
that point and i can plot it in a six dimensional
equation space in all of these six coordinate axes
and that's exactly what jared did so this is
just two slices in equation space of all of
those points and you'll see that the data appears
to live on these kind of subspaces or clusters so
jared applies relatively simple machine learning
clustering in this case gaussian mixture models
to find which clusters are active how
the data clusters and i'm only showing
you a couple slices so there's other dimensions
where the other terms cluster and again dominant
balance is about trying to figure out which
terms are small almost zero and which terms
are big and are balancing each other so what
we're going to try to do for example this red
this red set of points here this red cluster this
term is approximately zero and these two terms
are in a balance so we're also going to apply
sparse subspace identification or sparse pca to
find which terms are active approximately active
and which terms are approximately zero for each
of these five clusters and so again these black
squares are the terms that are approximately zero
and what's really cool is that every point
here you can re-plot that point in space where
it was in space and you find that these five
regimes of dominant balance correspond to five
classical regimes from from the boundary
layer so we recover the viscous sublayer the
inertial subway layer the transitional region
purely in an automated data-driven fashion
so this is phenomenal this allows us to
actually uncover these dominant balance regimes
purely from data with relatively simple sparse
modeling right we're trying to find the sparsest
combination of terms that are active in these
clusters and again this ca recapitulates classic
boundary layer theory that was hard fought over
the last hundred years by many many smart people
so we've looked at this for the boundary layer i
just showed you uh we've looked at this for the
super continuum laser this high energy optical
pulse propagation this is a really cool example
because this is a very non-linear system this
is non-linear wave physics but it turns out when
you do this dominant balance the only region in
the xt diagram where nonlinear terms are active
is in this tiny thin blue layer here so all
of the nonlinearity is actually very localized
in this in this problem we've applied this to
geophysical flows like the flow in the gulf of
mexico from the hicom data and we've relearned
kind of the classic geostrophic balances
and we're hoping to learn new balance
laws new almost invariances in the flow
that might have been missed by by humans that
might have been too complicated to write down
we're applying this to neuroscience data and the
real promise here is to apply this to fields where
we don't know the answer where we don't know about
the transitional region and the inertial sub layer
problems like neuroscience where we can learn
new dominant balance laws and simplified physics
in different regions of space and time
so i'm super super excited about that
and i hope you are too i hope you use uh this
for your own problems i hope you extend the
method and you know apply this to new problems
to discover new models that we didn't have before
so i'm super excited about where this is and i'm
looking forward to making another video in five
years uh you know what sparse non-linear models we
have you know in 2025 or 2026. all right thank you